de nouveau dénoncé "l'invasion
illégale", a-t-il dit,
de l'Ukraine par la Russie.
Et M. Trudeau a dit que Vlad
Poutine avait commis des crimes,
était responsable de crimes de
guerre odieux et qu'il sera tenu
responsable, qu'il devra r
des comptes. Et en ce jour, en
ce 8 mai, jour de commémoration
de la capitulation
de l'Allemagne nazie en 1945,
il a tenu à dire ceci :
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- Vladimir Poutine est en train
de faire honte à la mémoire,
aux millions de Russes qui ont
lutté, qui ont fait
des sacrifices pour vaincre
le fascisme, pour assurer
la liberté.
- Alors, le Canada va fournir
un nouveau soutien militaire à
l'Ukraine, y compris des drones
avec e e e e et des technologies
d'images satellites.
Et quand on a demandé
ymymymymymyr Zelensky
si le Canada en faisait
suffisamment pour aiderrarararau
qu'il y avait trois pays,
les républiques baltes, à quiUkn
demander de plus, parce qu'elles
avaient tout donné. Et il a dit
que le Canada, c'éêêêêêême
chose pour le Canada.
- Céline, un peu plus tôt,
Justin Trudeau a pu constater
la dévastation causée par
l'armée russe dans la ville
libérée d'Irpin.
- Oui, c'est là qu'il s'est
rendu tout de suite en arrivant.
Donc, Irpin, il est aussi allé
à Boutcha, donc des villes où...
qui ont été occupées par
les forces russes, et où
les forces russes sont accusées
d'avoir commis des massacres.
On parle d'exécutions, de viols,
de torture. Justin Trudeau
a donc pu voir par lui-même,
un peu, la destruction
et l'horreur, la brutalité
de cette guerre. Et ce qui l'a
frappé, c'est la résilience.
C'est la détermination
des ukrainiens qui ont su
repousser les forces russes.
Et il a dit conserver la
capitale. Plus tôt, il est aussi
allé rouvrir l'ambassade
du Canada en Ukraine. Il a...Ape
ratée, il a réussi à hisser
le drapeau en haut d'un mât,
sur le de l'ambassade.
Vous savez, il y à une trentaine
de pays qui avaient déjà repris
leurs activités diplomatiques
depuis plusieurs jours déjà,
plusieurs semaines. Donc,
le Canada a un peu tardé, mais
voilà, c'est fait. Les activités
vont reprendre. Monsieur Trudeau
donc qui est reparti ce soir,
après une journée passée ici,
à Kiev.
- Et puis, demain soir, Céline,
vous nous donnez rendez-vous
depuis Kiev pour une émissio